dynamic because i just did
a quick google search here and it's 14.5
of the us population that's over six
foot tall
the vast majority of american men are
not over six foot tall
damn but like almost 100 percent of
women i mean i'm rounding it up a little
bit but let's say like 90 95 percent of
women almost always insist on dating
somebody that's over
six foot tall and when they see six foot
tall they're usually coming up with
numbers like
must be over six foot two or must be
over six with three to date me and it's
like
what is this you know clacky moose
bringing to the table right you know you
can laugh and shrug a lot of these off
but just understand like the amount of
mental gymnastics that a lot of women go
through when they try to rationalize
these
lists of requirements you don't need to
be over six foot tall because
basically 85 percent of the u.s
population ain't
and one funny thing too is that uh when
we bring girls on the show and it's even
worse so like
a six foot is 14.5 to any guy to get a
guy
over six foot two is only three percent
of the population and then over six four
is about one percent
so i want to let you guys talk from it i
just gotta grab my phone it's ringing
hold on yeah yeah no worries
um so one of the other funny things guys
uh that are watching the show if you
guys catch our podcast late at night
you would know that one of the things we
asked the girls is hey well what do you
want in a guy
and almost every girl universally says
like i want a guy over six feet tall
despite how short they are they're gonna
want a guy over six feet tall
yeah so you know and then we say well
hey did you know that only
you know 15 of the male population is
over six feet and over only three
percent is over six for two and we tell
them these numbers are like oh
i didn't realize that uh you know what
i'm saying so it's very
interesting to see them kind of like uh
the delusion is real guys but like
that's why it's so important being [ __ ]
that's to the point as well
like females think they know what they
want right actually and they see on
social media they see online okay this
guy's living a certain lifestyle
he may be a certain height maybe he may
be fit and that's all they see
yeah so i would say rich 85 percent of
guys are like invisible to females
because they see a certain
type of guy and that's their go-to guy
that they always date
so when they get curved when they get
like left on scene all stuff
they're saying oh guys are no good but
they're talking about the top percent of
guys that they actually
want so that way like i'll be honest
it's
it's not that hard to do it's gonna take
work and discipline with diet and
exercise but
like chris moffitt just pointed out here
in the members chat he said
v taper broad shoulders and a slim waist
so we're not talking like a bodybuilder
we're not talking power lifter we're
talking a swimmer's body
yeah and i achieved the optics of that
the first time that i recognized that i
achieved the optics of that was when i
was dating this chick and i was down at
the air show down in the fall here in
toronto
and i was standing up on this part of
the wall and she had her friends over
there
and they made a sarcastic sl slash
appreciative comment which was something
along the lines of
hey can you tell the calvin klein model
over there to pull up his pants you know
we can see his underwear and his sex
lines right
i'll show you what i look like because
here's a a picture from around the time
uh let me pull up yeah and rich
you're in really good shape for a guy
your age man and i still work out though
right i mean like
i i had achieved that by around the age
of 23.
broad shoulders v taper you know low
belly fat that's all that you need you
know of course i had a look and here i
was going for the tom cruise look from
top gun
like you have to do the work on yourself
if you want to achieve the look
that's going to present the optics of
attraction um
my girlfriend at that time she got super
jealous when that comment went out and
you know the other ladies were
you know pining and all that sort of
stuff but it's not that hard like
at that time when i was there i probably
had like a mental
like a limiting mental belief somewhere
along the lines of what i used to call
bigorexia meaning i never thought i was
big enough i was like i never thought i
was
more or that i wasn't muscular enough or
anything like that
and women don't really want that i think
in that picture because i'm about six
foot three i was probably about 200
pounds
okay i'm about 210 pounds now because
i'm on trt so i hold a little bit more
water in my body
but overall you don't need to be like a
250 pound you know six foot three months
or anything like that just signal the
optics
of a swimmer's body so think of like
guys like michael phelps you know for
example
that that is definitely the ideal
woman's body most guys overestimate and
i did a whole youtube video on this that
like
most guys overestimate what the
aesthetic look is for females
right about 50 pounds or so over what
women are really attracted to as long as
you've got that
1.62 shoulder to waist ratio and you
know you're not like fat
you're gonna be attractive to most women
with that especially in the west where
obesity is a real thing yeah i'm
realizing too once you get into shape
and like
you get the v-tape and the slim waist
you actually gain height when you do
that
yes don't talk about that but you guys
should look taller when you get into
shape yeah and look
this is the easiest way for you to enter
the high value marketplace because guess
what
when you're in fitness in your shape
people respect you off rip yep
especially females too
exactly so yeah i would say that's those
are that's the way
from a visual standpoint i think that's
the best way a guy can self-improve is
getting in shape especially if they're
under six feet tall it's basically a
non-negotiable yep
you